today's topic I guess um fresh and fit
ended our career with last night's
Hearthstone
I think we're the first ones really
calling them out at this point they 've
been lying me off for years and they're
dumb
broad fresh and fraud you know Prince is
like it looks like you should see him
build momentum what the [__]
ing imagine them
looks like a monkey creatures over there
looking like Magilla Grill and Donkey
Kong having a baby
I do
I use them
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
reach reach listen to me that these
dudes have been talking [__] for years
and I think the thing is that they've
been kind of coasting on is You Gotta
Fight Fire with Fire and we're gonna be
nice guys we're gonna toss your salad oh
no we got some accessories here okay I
got some apples and peaches here as
y'all can see okay some great fruits
yeah then we also put some peaches some
milk as well have you seen our reach
close clubbing
man
no no reach I don't even believe in this
Theory but you gotta
evolved
welcome to freshers
if you guys didn't understand the
stereotype it's like black people are
not evolved and so he's saying preachers
are unevolved black person essentially
dude
[Music]
[Laughter]
what the [__] is going on welcome
you're overdosing on the warrior Gene
bro
but don't [__] throw that spear these
are disgusting animals that's why they
look like animals these guys are [__]
animals bro who are the [__] runs
with all fours like a [__] animal
okay
I don't know what in Clayton Bixby you
guys were thinking
okay Uncle Ruckus no relation
I don't know how you guys did it
would you guys made a more embarrassing
response than h3h3 by like a long mile
Oh my days they don't even know I don't
think they're smart enough to understand
what they just did they're not smart
enough I think they know that they have
negative feelings about black people
that's no I don't think they do so to
them they don't I don't think they even
comprehend that I disagree
um I think some people just got
anti-black sentiments and they just
don't want to acknowledge it just
because you don't want to acknowledge it
doesn't mean you don't know it's there
it's like you know you got to mess under
the table [__] just because you didn't
look don't mean you don't know what's
there what you're saying you got you got
you got a white dude coming on talking
about spear chucking like using every
racist Trope I'd have ever heard from a
white business in regards to black
people you're out here making monkey
noises about a black person I mean you
could just drop the heart and ER on the
n-word because it's the same [__] might
as well Spirit checking that's messed up
but what even the warrior jeans they're
basically trying to say black or animals
I understand you just he's using
scientific language yeah you already
said that yeah you already said that
yeah and your name people that [__]
goober to say that watching them run
around and and do these kinds of poses
for 30 minutes I'm like okay I guess
this is just how high value men act in
the privacy of their home yes when they
mad about something they don't make
business moves they don't do things
strategically they're not running around
like monkeys they make monkeys that's a
high value that's a high value this
guy's apparently now the new leader of
the red pill yes okay and this is what
he's like that's our value on camera
imagine behind closed doors so I'm just
saying I mean monkey noise and put a wig
on and parade around I've known many
great leaders I don't think I've ever
seen one act that's embarrassing as him
bro you are a [__] promo that's
that's a rebuttal
you do contemporary dance therefore
you're gay that's Abba the salsa so
that's it imagine doing a dance with
women where you go out to a place and
you dance with women pretty much the
entire evening and that's
[Music]
it
probably six dudes in there six dudes in
there doing Monkey noises and laughing
and high-fiving each other and to you
the Apex of masculinity is you chilling
with a bunch of dudes high-fiving each
other in a room
well I mean while we dancing with girls
and that's what makes us gay that's how
you think
that's your logic I think they mentioned
that because they think it hurts us or
they would hurt our fan base but if
you're secure in who you are and your
masculinity it doesn't bother you
whether someone calls you gay or not no
it's never bothered me
because one I know I'm straight two I
don't need to project that outward I
don't care if you think I'm straight or
not because I'm not trying to [__] you
who cares
why would I care what random men think
about my sexuality sometimes I think
it's funny because in the black
community they're like so obsessed with
not seeming gay that they'll be like
pause even I like to play to that
because it's just funny to me to like be
like oh that right it's a character of a
character but if you ask me like are you
gay I'm like
do you think so
sure whatever I really don't give a [__]
that has never been something that
bothered me but anyways
um as for all the whole racist tirade it
is what it is
I'm just saying if a white person that
said even half this [__] on their own
podcast that [__] would never but a
white person it is a white person could
never weigh it away with coming up here
and let me also say this it's not better
because it comes from a black person no
it's not better in fact I think
sometimes it's even worse Uncle Ruckus
because under the veil of like this is
somehow acceptable we're perpetuating
and thinking susceptible to refer to
black people as monkeys even if an Asian
person wants to come out here and do
braided eyes and going I don't think
that's acceptable either it's not
because you belong to a group that all
of a sudden all your credibly raised
actions like I don't think YouTube would
ever allow people to get up here and
call other black people whether it's a
black person or not that n-word with a
heart ER right why because we all
recognize even if it comes from a black
person that shit's still wrong so
there's just a bunch of weird stuff
that's happening here but
y'all roll how y'all want to roll if
that's the kind of heat that you want to
work on yourselves go right ahead so
just really not you go watch it yourself
so you guys can go make your own
judgments but uh this is the only part
that I thought was worth addressing
because I think there might be a bit of
a misunderstanding but let's play wow he
makes this accusation right here my
other boys you won't [__] me then you
can't get on the platform so wait you
want to bang a girl who just wants to
come on the platform for clout and you
think that's burning desire
but he doesn't show y'all the entire
conversation of her talking [__] for
hours on hours on hours on hours to me I
want you guys to pause right that moment
he knew she had contact with her so just
to collab he asks her multiple times and
she's single and married she's thinking
oh she's being invited to be on a dating
show to talk about dating she finally
says like okay yeah after the third time
he asked like oh or second time he said
yeah you know what I am single
and he's like perfect well listen I
don't collab with people who I'm
platonic with out of nowhere it's in the
text messages and she says what do you
mean she's like well we're not just
going to be just friends if you want to
collab you are doing sex for a Time on
the podcast which is what we initiated
initially said so I don't know why he
showed this conversation as if I'm lying
about what happened then I respond I'm
just being honest to stand by I'm not
collaborating with you unless we [__]
why do I say that
you guys say oh yo Byron we could let it
go let it go would y'all Let It Go if
someone said some [__] like this
about you on a big ass podcast with 4
million subscribers [__] what am I going
to spend my day socializing with
somebody who's like
hold on
podcast don't take my word for it at
some point Adam asked me like yo you
guys could totally be friends again or
whatever I'm like I ain't [__] with
people like that I don't want to be with
people who harm their communities I
don't want to be involved with people
who are like I give an example of
somebody I wouldn't want to be
Associated one of them was another one
was someone who goes around stealing
from people okay you can see right now
DJ Envy getting in trouble because a
person he associated with goes around
stealing from his community I don't want
to be associated with people who go harm
folks from my area the same way I don't
want to be associated with a podcast
like this that I think is harmful that's
it because if you guys notice whenever
the allegations came out well I don't
remember when it was he did a live
stream about it it came out after I did
this interview so I didn't even know
about that so and also if I hated you
guys so much and I want to take you down
so badly why wouldn't I ever mention
that kind of thing on our videos why
would I make yo Myron he goes around
people I've never done that I've never
made a video like that I've never said
it in a single YouTube video that we do
ourselves okay
but in this offhand comment where I'm
talking about not being associated with
people who harm their communities and I
use an example one you think that's
directly you and I can understand
probably with everything going on and
hearing that for me
I could understand why you could take it
that way but it's not what I meant nor
if you look at the greater context of
everything I said about this whole
ordeal it's never been something I've
said I mean so let me be clear I don't
know if this guy is I've never alleged
that he is and that's not my position
today we're actually defending on that
so uh we were defending them on that so
so yeah they're stupid to call them one
thing and defend them on the same thing
so yeah he's saying it's political he's
saying we're doing it politically sure
which is sure you can you can believe
that whatever you're gonna believe
whatever you want to believe and I think
that's partially my fault because the
way I left the door open was not being
abundantly clear yeah honestly guys
um it wasn't even entertaining and I was
like Tom briefs like do we really want
to do like a whole thing where we roast
every point it's not worth it no because
we're doing this for we're doing that
for people that are not smart enough to
comprehend not smart enough to have a
conversation it's like it's okay man the
what you that was your retort to
whatever the hell we said everything
that we said that was you replying the
monkey noises and also think it's just
really wild are you that comfortable
ladies and why do call you the n-word
all the time I know for a fact he's
comfortable with most of the people you
associated with the red pill calling on
the n-word but yeah
that's that's how they roll that's how
you roll could be me anything else nah
as a Haitian we don't claim him bro oh
God we don't claim you
foreign
[Music]